What's wrong?
I'm just dealing with some stuff right now.
What kinds of stuff?
Anxiety, rejection, theory already paralysis,character issues,moral issues you know, life stuff.
Charlie won big state white cooking competition a couple years ago. The kid's a genius in the kitchen.
Are you going to Brooks tomorrow night?
Everyone's gonna be there.
Oh great.
Then I can explain everyone individually, that I still live at home when they're about to run their own company.
What happened with that girl from the coffee shop?
You can make this happen. You're Charlie Runner!
That's the problem.
Hi.
Listen, I was just wanted to tell you that I..I see you in here all the time and then I just...
Okay, uh, have a nice day.
Huh..it could have been worse.
Not really...
Hi, I just wanted to say hello after what happened back there.
So, how come you work in a movie theater instead of a restaurant?
Well, it..its incase seeing what's happening all around me.
I'm terrified that I'm so content and terrified that I'm so not.
Can't let fear failure run your life.
Why won't you talk to me?
I don't have all the answers yet.
I don't get you. I mean, you're smart
and
you're nice and you're funny.
I'm not funny.
Well, maybe not on purpose.
Sometimes, no matter how hard it is you just got a step to the plate.
Just sounds like a bad t-shirt.
You know it's funny. She's the only girl I have really felt charming around.
What's wrong with you?
I'm just trying to concentrate on giving myself an aneurysm.
You're not charming. That's the thing. I don't know.